[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich euch bitten würde euch ein land
vorzustellen in dem mehr als 80 prozent
der bevölkerung in staatlich geförderten
sozialwohnung leben würdet ihr sicher an
eine sozialistische republik vielleicht
ein land des ehemaligen ostblocks oder
ein skandinavisches lang mit
aufgeblähten sozialstaat denken nicht
war aber was wäre wenn ich euch verraten
würde dass wir eine derart hohe quote an
sozialwohnungen in einem land mit einer
der frühesten und am stärksten der
regulierten wirtschaftssysteme der welt
vorfinden können möglicherweise handelt
es sich sogar um das kapitalistische
land der welt überhaupt das würde euch
durchaus überraschen nicht wahr
nun singapur ist ein ungewöhnlicher fall
eine absolute ausnahme in sachen
wohnungsmarkt
[Musik]
die südostasiatische stadtstaat der für
hoch aufragende wolkenkratzer eine
unmögliche architektur und als eines der
größten finanzzentren der welt bekannt
ist hat ein weltweit einzigartiges
staatliches wohnungs system entwickelt
einige von euch denken vielleicht aber
mag du hast uns bereits über die stadt
wien erzählt in der st ein ähnlich
starkes überaus erfolgreichen start
dieses modell dafür gibt nun ja du hast
recht wir sprechen jedoch von zwei sich
sehr stark unterscheidenden modellen der
größte unterschied zwischen dem wiener
modell und dem in singapur liegt vor
allem im anteil der immobilien besetzen
während das wiener stark mit orientiert
ist drei viertel der wiener leben im
städtischen mietwohnungen haben wir in
singapur das genaue gegenteil davon mehr
als 90 prozent der bürger singapur ist
besitzen ein eigenes haus oder eine
eigene wohnung insgesamt werden 80
prozent der eigenheime vom staat
garantiert gefördert und gebaut
ja wir sprechen hier über ein system
eigentums orientierter sozialwohnungen
allerdings gibt es dabei einen kleinen
haken wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind aber
darüber erfahrt ihr später mehr
zuerst müssen wir uns einige fragen
stellen aus welchem grund lehnt gerade
ist singapur
das modell der freien marktwirtschaft
immobilienbereich ab wie um alles in der
welt können sie ein eigentums
orientiertes öffentliches wohnungs
system entwickeln wie hat sich dieses
modell auf den privaten immobilienmarkt
ausgewirkt und kann das modell von
singapur auf andere länder übertragen
werden in diesem video werden wir allen
diesen fragen auf den grund gehen
[Musik]
zynga wenig land und viel bevölkerung
liebe freunde von visual politik
zunächst müssen wir uns mit den kodex
vertraut machen sehen wir uns diese
karte
[Applaus]
singapur ist ein stadtstaat mit etwas
mehr als 700 quadratkilometern aber mit
mehr als fünfeinhalb millionen
einwohnern
dies hat dazu geführt dass mehr als 70
prozent des landes bebaut werden mussten
das sind die roten bereiche auf der
karte die restlichen 30% meisten
naturschutzgebiet oderland auf den man
gar nicht bauen kann im grunde genommen
ist die stadt überfüllt
angesichts eines solchen szenarios wäre
es gar nicht so abwegig davon auszugehen
dass einem die wohnungssuche in singapur
so einige kopfschmerzen bereiten würde
oder
immerhin ist dies an ähnlichen
ordentlich zum beispiel hongkong
durchaus der fall nun seltsamerweise
nicht in singapur der grund dafür hat
viel mit dem einzigartigen stadt
entwicklungsmodells singapurs zu tun
seht euch mal folgendes an 1960 gründete
die regierung singapur ist us housing
and development board ein öffentliches
wohnungsunternehmen das für die
regulierung und verwaltung von
grundstücken sowie für den bau und
entwicklung von immobilienprojekten
zuständig ist und das liegt daran dass
sich seit 1967 der größte teil des
baulandes in singapur in öffentliche ist
in jedem jahr 1967 wurde das sogenannte
gesetz über den landerwerb verabschiedet
das ist der regierung ermöglichte wieder
in den besitz sämtlicher baukunst zu
kommen das bedeutet dass die für die
immobilienentwicklung vermarktung
grundstück und nach den kriterien des
hauses boards zur verfügung gestellt
werden dadurch gibt es kein freies
preissystem bei der vermarktung von
bauch
[Musik]
okay lass mich das noch mal anders
erklären die öffentliche hand bestimmt
wie viele häuser sie bauen wird und zu
welchen preisen und bedingungen
diese vermarktet werden und auch
sichtlich geschieht dies immer unterhalb
des potentiellen marktpreises auf der
anderen seite ist es dieser organisation
das housing development board welche
land an private bauträger versteigert
die dort ihre kommerziellen immobilien
projekt umsetzen können natürlich bleibt
das land in jedem fall weiterhin
öffentlichen eigentum das heißt die
besitzer der immobilien können mit
diesen nicht tun und lassen was sie
wollen
sie können beispielsweise ihr haus nicht
verkaufen damit an seiner stelle ein
hotel errichtet wird somit handelt es
sich nicht wirklich um
immobilieneigentum sondern eher um eine
pacht mit einer laufzeit von 99 jahren
nach dieser zeit geht die immobilie
wieder allen stars zurück ach ja und
ausländer erhalten in singapur keine
neuen sozialwohnungen dafür muss man
schon die dortige staatsangehörigkeit
besitzen aber lassen wir uns an dieser
stelle das system noch mal durch den
premierminister von singapur
höchstselbst leute
nach 99 jahren kehrt die wohnung wieder
in staatsbesitz zurück dieser saniert
das land und baut neue wohnungen für
zukünftige generationen nur so kann die
immobilie recycelt werden damit alle
unsere nachkommen neue eigene wohnungen
kaufen können wenn die regierung
stattdessen eigentumswohnungen verkaufen
würde würde uns früher oder später das
land ausgehen um neue wohnungen zu bauen
wie sie in long premierminister von
singapur
man muss vorsichtig sein denn bei
privaten bauprojekten kann dieser
zeitraum noch kürzer sein natürlich
können die eigentümer während dieser
zeit mit dem haus tun was sie für
angemessen halten wenn sich darin wohnen
wollen können sie es verkaufen oder
vermieten
tatsächlich es ist nicht ungewöhnlich
dass wenn es gut läuft diejenigen die
elternhäuser besitzen die staatlichen
häuser verkaufen oder vermieten welche
in der regel sehr einfach ausgestattet
sind waren die alten um dann in private
wohnanlagen zu ziehen die in singapur
weitaus mehr luxus bieten aber die
eigenheiten dieses merkwürdigen systems
endlich damit noch lange nicht die
institution welche die meisten häuser
baut und verkauft staatlich ist selbst
die regierung sie als sozialpolitisches
instrument ein oder besser gesagt eine
instrument des social engineering um zum
beispiel die bildung von ghettos zu
verhindern bevölkerung singapurs eine
gewisse ethnische vielfalt aufweist
werden die wohnungen inhalt eines
gebäudes oder einer ganzen siedlung so
verteilt dass der anteil der eigentümer
eine ethnische verteilung hat welche die
verteilung im ganzen land widerspiegelt
die bevölkerungs verteilung medien in
singapur sieht in etwa so aus wenn ein
wohnblock oder ein projekt zum beispiel
100 häuser hat dann wohnen dort 74
chinesische 13 malaysische und neun
indische familie das ist doch gar keine
so schlechte idee nicht machen
[Musik]
eine nicht unumstrittene aspekt dieses
ist jedoch dass die regierung die
gewährung von wohnraum zur förderung
bestimmte lebensmodelle nutzt zum
beispiel haben traditionelle paare keine
probleme bei der bewerbung um eine
staatliche immobilie aber dass singles
oder gleichgeschlechtliche paare drücken
wir mal so aus für sie ist es viel viel
komplizierter überrascht das ist es
nicht seltsam einen derartigen
staatsinterventionismus an einem
angeblich erzkatholischen ort zu finden
nun eigentlich ist es gar nicht so
überraschend wie wir bereits gesagt
haben das politische wirtschaftliche und
soziale modell singapurs ist eine art
mischung aus marktwirtschaftlich
kapitalistischer politik und eine sehr
sehr paternalistischen politik bei der
der staat bestimmte lebensweisen aktiv
fördert und andere bestraft in diesem
fall sind im bereich des wohnungswesen
ist nicht nur bei der wohnungsvergabe
sondern zum beispiel auch bei der
genehmigung von hypotheken die
bedingungen für personen die die
staatlich vorgegebenen kriterien
erfüllen sehr vorteilhaft und wenn man
sie nicht erfüllt ja dann hat man pech
gehabt du willst lieber alleine leben
und in ruhe gelassen werden
das geht nicht oder doch nicht ganz
alleine aber mit einem freund in einer
wg nix da mit einem
gleichgeschlechtlichen partner nun wir
würden ja gerne helfen aber um das geht
leider auch recht nun abgesehen von
diesen eher fragwürdigen praktiken ist
dieses system in der tat recht
erfolgreich wohnraum allgemein ist in
singapur fiel viel erschwinglicher als
in anderen städten mit vergleichbarer
einkommens wie zum beispiel london
sydney oder hoch im durchschnitt geben
neue käufer weniger als ein viertel
ihres einkommens für ihre hypothek aus
aber ein mensch denn da wäre noch ein
anderer haken das alles gibt es nicht
umsonst
[Musik]
aber wer zahlt die rechnung wenn die
regierung von singapur für eine sache
bekannt ist dann dafür die einnahmen und
ausgaben der öffentlichen hand eine
balance zu halten weil ihrem
sozialwohnung system sieht es jedoch
ganz anders aus
bb meldet 1,47 milliarden dollar verlust
der letzten geschäftsjahr da weniger
wohnungen verkauft wurden
channel news asia anderthalb milliarden
dollar das ist die differenz zwischen
den kosten für den bau von
infrastrukturen häusern auf der einen
seite und den einnahmen aus dem verkauf
der wohnungen auf der anderen seite das
sind 10 5 milliarden dollar die aus dem
öffentlichen haushalt finanziert werden
müssen
das gesamte sozialwohnung system wird im
wesentlichen also über steuern
finanziert unabhängig vom land besitzt
ist dies der jährliche zuschuss mit dem
der staat seine wohnungspolitik
subventioniert
im grunde handelt es sich um einen
durchaus akzeptablen betrag für eine so
große volkswirtschaft wie die singapur
es bedeutet dies nun dass die
regierungen anderer länder massenhaft
baugrundstücke verstaatlichen und den
wohnungsbau planwirtschaftlich
kontrollieren sollten so wie es die
regierung in singapur tut ganz und gar
nicht der fall singapur ist sehr
speziell gesprächen von einem stadtstaat
mit großen wirtschaftlichen erfolg einem
staat der fast wie ein unternehmen
geführt wird und in dem die
geografischen bedingungen die
landnutzung extrem stark einschränkt die
unterschiede zu anderen ländern sind
ganz offensichtlich und es ist auch
nicht ganz klar dass ein freier
immobilienmarkt in singapur nicht auch
gut funktionieren würde
ganz zu schweigen von der enormen macht
die ein solches system den politiker in
die hand liegt macht die dann
ideologisch missbraucht werden kann zum
beispiel um durch social engineering die
freiheit der menschen einzuschränken
aber was singapur mit diesem modell
wirklich erreicht hat und ich denke es
ist nicht zu leugnen war die entwicklung
eines stadtplanungs und immobilienpreise
systems welches die entwicklung viele
andere aktivitäten mit größeren mehrwert
begünstigt sowie vorteile und freiheiten
in vielen anderen lebensbereichen
schafft die es so nicht geben würde
da die wohnungspreise gedeckelt sind
verfügen die bürger singapurs über eine
größere freiheit geld für andere dinge
wie zum beispiel ihre altersvorsorge zu
sparen
diese überschüsse können sie dann auch
gewinnbringend anlegen und
beispielsweise in neue innovative
unternehmen investieren denn je größer
das geldpolster ist auf den man sich
bettet desto mehr kann man riskieren
ohne gleich in existenzielle not zu
geraten ein einzigartiges modell das
eine debatte allemal wert ist denn in
vielen anderen ländern bleibt den
menschen nach abzug hoher
lebenshaltungskosten sowie steuern und
sozialabgaben nur sehr wenig spielraum
ihr leben wirtschaftlich innovativ und
frei zu gestalten denn finanzielle
freiheit ist auch ein stück freiheit und
in singapur ist sie eben nicht nur für
die ganz reichen da sondern man kann sie
in hohem maße genießen wenn man zum
durchschnitt gehört so und jetzt seid
ihr dran was haltet ihr von der
wohnungspolitik singapurs wenn ihr in
singapur leben würde würden für euch die
vorteile die nachteile überwiegen
schreibt uns eure meinungen in den
kommentarbereich und wisst ihr
eigentlich dass wir jede woche neu
und informative videos für euch
vorbereitet und veröffentlicht wenn ihr
also keines dieser aktuellen updates
verpassen wollt abonniert wird visuell
politik und drückt dann auch auf die
pflege taste wenn euch dieses video
gefallen hat dann geht uns auch einen
daumen hoch bis zum nächsten
[Musik]